hey guys Benjamin's back here again
doing another resume review this time
we're taking a look at a car Mohamed's
resume and I'm also going to do a
portfolio review that someone else had
provided but I'm gonna put that in a
separate video and probably put that on
my own channel I'm going to reserve the
resume reviews directly for my channel
and for Reese indication on free code
camp ok so I have this basic intake form
set up you guys can find the link to
this in the description as well and
basically I just have a little
disclaimer saying hey make sure you're
removing phone numbers your address
email address from your resume unless
you're comfortable with the email
address being included and required did
that so that's great you know he does
have his email address and he's
comfortable sharing that let's see and
then he also wanted to share his Twitter
profile github what he's interested in
and which industry is interested in ok
didn't fill out an industry but that's
fine let's see wants to be a junior web
developer and ok we have his social
media profile here for Twitter so I'm
just going to go ahead and open all
these up we also got github so we're
going to do a resume review gonna take a
quick look at his portfolio site but not
really focus on it because that's not
the the focus of this video and then
that's just a link to our resume cool
just gonna take a look I do like that
the the contact info is up here I dig
the layout nice thick horizontal lines
same thing with the text used and great
contrast of text colors as well you know
definitely with the orange getting all
of the pertinent details popping out and
different font faces love that great
design overall really dig the layout
let's see yeah so overall love the
layout let's let's just go from the top
so let's see as a highly motivated and
results oriented manager within the tech
field have a
proven track record of providing
exemplary levels of service along with
high-quality technical and digital
content strategy yeah I think that
that's a solid intro one thing I think I
would maybe focus on a little bit more
is highlighting some examples of high
technical quality you know you mentioned
a proven track record so perhaps put in
some metrics there but I'll continue
reviewing the resume and then we'll get
back to that same thing let's see
digital content strategy I would
recommend maybe some digital content
projects that you've worked on listing
those or perhaps listing different types
of as a digital marketing like search
engine optimization for example or
conversion rate optimisation or
analytics something a little bit more
specific to include concrete details
again I think a lot of people may
disagree with me on this but I
definitely think that you should have
longer than just a one pager I think you
should have and this is just personal
opinion to have your relevant skills
kind of near the top relevant projects
near the top especially if you're a
junior dev you don't really want to be
leading in with experience that doesn't
necessarily tie into the web development
job that you're seeking ideally I would
you know like in this published article
section have a few of your github
repositories or projects and have those
kind of near the top maybe under the
overview in between experience yeah
probably in between experience and then
maybe moved articles up a little bit
because honestly in my experience a lot
of recruiters that I've worked with and
hiring managers haven't really ever
asked about my education or skills the
only exceptions of that is they'll just
say hey do you have a four-year degree
but they never ask where's the four-year
degree from they never ask what's your
GPA so one thing to keep in mind there I
would recommend putting your Education
and Skills near the bottom and
highlighting your
projects as essentially you want to be
saying through the hiring manager look
this is the work that I've done I can
complete projects and here are the the
projects that I have completed so
definitely you know check them out and
you know showcase your work that way
anyway I feel like I've kind of covered
that quite a bit so let's see we have a
signature design consultants Ltd company
director ok providing consultancy and
technical support to SME I'm not sure
what that means on digital and web
strategy for web and mobile applications
and digital marketing ok well out of
curiosity this isn't something a hiring
manager or anyone like that it's
probably gonna do again I mentioned they
only review a resume for probably about
I would say 30 seconds or so if you're
lucky ok so this probably stands for
small and medium-sized enterprises or
small and medium-sized businesses cool
cool
got that instead of putting SME I would
recommend maybe listing a couple of
clients they're proud of working with
you know a couple maybe say two
medium-sized businesses and one small
sized business you know I just use that
general rule of three to really market
to you know people's mindset and kind of
short-term memory so that those few
clients that you've worked with stick in
their memory I would also elaborate on
consultancy and technical support like
what sort of projects did you consult on
what kind of technical support did you
provide and I know you mentioned web and
mobile applications and digital strategy
but I would recommend mentioning one
some of the clients that you worked with
as I mentioned and to some of the
projects that you worked on for those
clients so again you're just really
highlighting the projects and work that
you've done like I said I really do like
the layout really do like the use of
fonts and I really do like the color
contrast they've used okay and then
total airport marketing consultant you
know make it make it past tense and kind
of break this up because this is just
kind of one like run-on sentence
you could either break it out into a
couple of different ways to display it
you could break it out into say bullet
points like say there's a bullet point
and then you know that next part is a
bullet point for training and then the
other one is you know the amount of
sales that you did then boom you got
three solid bullet points you're using
the rule of three and then you're also
providing your facts and figures it's
easy to read and it's in past tense so
yeah overall I think good content in
there can be reworded a little bit and
instead of doing these kind of like
run-on sentences where you're trying to
smush everything together just break
them out into bullet points it'll be
easier for people to skim let's see
Stansberry supermarkets department
manager okay cool so I imagine here
you're trying to highlight some of your
managerial experience I'm looking at it
now this is October 2013 was the
endpoint and it we're already in
November if a team typically I wouldn't
list anything later than you know five
years ago in the past it's honestly I
would recommend just removing this
adding a little bit more you know
allowing it to free up a little bit more
space and then as I mentioned earlier
providing some of those projects that
you've worked on and listing that
they're you know as you as you can
notice you can probably spot a trend
here I'm just trying to highlight
projects projects projects skim ability
okay cool and then you have some of your
skills web related skills
now I understand probably why you kept
it this way you wanted to make it clean
and skimmable yeah honestly I would
recommend heading in more skills here
strike that balance between keyword
stuffing now if you're not familiar with
the phrase keyword stuffing is basically
just that taking these keywords or these
phrases and putting in things that are
relevant to the audience that you want
to get in front of and then just kind of
peppering a bunch of those in putting
putting a bunch of those in so I would
recommend writing down some other
technologies that you've worked with
like CSS great but maybe put CSS and
then css3 if you've worked with sass I
would also put in sass you know a CSS
preprocessor
if you worked with HTML I would also put
in html5 also anything that goes along
with laravel since that is a PHP
framework I would recommend putting in
PHP putting in any package managers that
go with that I believe that's symfony if
I'm not mistaken
same thing with JavaScript if you've
messed a little bit with node
you messed a little bit with react go
ahead and list those you want to be
transparent and you don't want to lie
about the amount of experience that you
have with a particular technology you
also though want to make sure that
you're giving yourself a running start
you're making sure that you're giving
yourself a decent chance of getting in
front of the right people listing every
technology especially when you're
starting out listing every technology
that you've touched it's marketing cool
and this is where you highlight on PPC
SEO SEM and digital content okay so
that's what you alluded to up here yeah
so let's let's go back to the the
overall overview here so as I mentioned
you may want to put in pick one or two
of these that you feel that you're the
strongest with and pepper those in and
kind of put those about your your
overview I feel like we've covered the
the resume pretty pretty well I'm just
gonna go ahead and pull up these
articles yeah this is good I mean it
does show your kind of political slant
as it mentions down here business models
politics also shows your interest in
entrepreneurship and kind of by proxy
your interest in the entertainment
sector which is fantastic I think though
as I mentioned I would probably save
this for your cover letter because on
your cover letter that's where you
really want to showcase your personality
and other aspects of what makes you up
as an individual whereas the resume is
more so just kind of the down-and-dirty
here's what I can do here's what I have
done you know that sort of thing your
experience your skills your projects
like a few different articles that I
think kind of show your personality in
general so I would say one about kind of
startup culture one about
social media and then one about say
security then that will kind of give a
decent holistic view of the things
you're interested in and with those you
just pick the best ones and present
those at the top of your cover letter
but um since you have two profiles you
have this one here this one's political
politics religion I would just avoid
that in general and go with this you
know this looks like a solid you know
code related profile you know you're
saying you're a lawyer previously and
now you're focused on software
engineering you like JavaScript and
laravel perfect this is what hiring
managers really like to see and you can
even include this in your cover letter
and you can elaborate on that a little
bit with a couple more sentences if you
want because people people love that
they know that lawyers are diligent they
know that you have to be focused you
have to study hard I'm not sure if you
had to pass some sort of a bar exam or
some sort of a you know like entry-level
exam but that's also another thing you
can kind of put out there there's
usually a good connotation associated
with lawyers and this is good you have a
sense of humor if I were a hiring
manager I'd want to see that I think you
had shared this with a meets a day this
is you on deaf too and you're basically
talking about the frustration between
learning a I think was a solid language
and learning a framework and you also
have decent engagement here with some of
the comments ORS which is fantastic this
would be an article honestly that I
would also put on your on your cover
letter the HR professional isn't going
to probably look at that the hiring
manager is more than likely going to be
looking at tech related sent that you do
share especially on Twitter okay and
you're also staying culturally relevant
to the overall developer community
you're talking about hacked over fast
could be part but felt like couldn't
this year not only did I take part I
bagged the t-shirt okay so you did
actually complete it
yeah dude so highlight that so I mean
like that keeps you
that helps tell a story it shows that
you're interested in open source that
again goes to some of the projects like
highlight some of those open source
projects on your resume and the the HR
professionals may not fully understand
what you're working on but if they see
those projects they'll at least have a
general idea okay this guy can do
something let's get this in front of a
hiring manager and get a second opinion
get an informed opinion and then when a
hiring manager sees it and he sees that
you contributes open source and he sees
that you're culturally relevant to
digital ocean and Oktoberfest and your
overall in the larger ecosystem of
development and you're engaged that's
gonna earn you a lot of brownie points
but yeah all together men love this
Twitter account definitely highlight in
the open source projects that you worked
on definitely highlights your sense of
humor and I would say definitely
highlight your your accomplishments with
aktobe er fest because that's that's no
easy task so great job with that you
have your portfolio we're just gonna
take a quick look at this
okay so you have your social media links
I'm not going to click through those
click on here awesome that's nice and
responsive nice layout
okay easily organized different use of
color like that talking about your focus
okay cool credit a P I is in laravel
framework and they're talking about
creating three applications crud and
api's yeah there you go dude like that's
that's some of your summary that's
that's some of your project bullet
points like seriously
boom you got a highlight right there you
know that's your that's your highlight
reel man you got to put that on display
front and center on your resume okay
cool and you're also talking about doing
blogging and basic video tutorials yeah
then you can basically use this as your
highlight reel to kind of start off the
section for your articles on your cover
letter today okay and they were also
talking about your work with free code
camp
you're talking about your future goals
fantastic as a junior developer people
are really going to want to see that you
still have plans to continue to grow and
continue to improve yourself and that
you're worth the investment of time and
money that they're putting into hiring
you as a junior asset definitely include
something like that in your cover letter
and I know this is controversial I would
recommend including the photo in your
cover letter or in your resume
some people will strongly disagree with
me on that but I think it's it's
worthwhile you know maybe get one that's
facing directly towards the camera and
you know maybe where like something
relatively professional but overall this
would be a fine photo as well okay but
again yeah
highly at real men projects you've
worked on put them front and center on
that resume okay and yep you also have a
portfolio looks like all of this is
pertaining to the free code camp
challenges cool but yeah I would
definitely recommend putting in some
highlights of the open source project so
that you contributes you for hack Tober
fest okay and then you have the contact
me cool and that's nice and simple yeah
in terms of the layout of this I love it
man
nice and responsive you know this is
definitely something I would also
highlight in your resume I'm probably
near the top with some social media
links and if you want to double down on
that also highlight that on your cover
letter because you want to get you know
the these projects and these bullet
points that you you know that you've
worked hard on in front of the the
hiring manager and the HR professional
cool it looks like you are highlighting
things that you actually have worked on
here and making use of the popular
repositories so that's great you do have
a fairly active graph here that's nice
to see and cool and then here are some
of the pull requests that you're working
on or a Octoberfest with free code camp
and these these other profiles I'm not
too familiar with yeah definitely as I
mentioned to highlight those I think
we've covered all the bases
I just want to thank you for sharing
this resume I know it's can be a bit
nerve-wracking to not only share your
resume with someone else and not only
share your social media presence with
someone else but to share it with my
audience and and everyone on free code
camps so hey big shout out to a car
Muhammad for sharing his some of his
contact info guys definitely reach out
to him his social media links are in the
description below
give him some kudos if you really like
his portfolio as much as I did give him
some kudos on this layout he did a great
job same thing with the the color
contrast and font use solid man really
dig it
so yeah you got a few things that you
can punch up make this a little bit more
scalable add in some more skills maybe
push these articles to your cover letter
highlight some of the other work that
you've done but I did do a deep dive and
it looks like you've put in the work you
you have a solid content out there and
you have a decent head for design and
for layout you just need to make it pop
and showcase those skills and projects a
little bit more and I think you'll be a
shoo-in for landing your first junior
developer position or maybe one of you
first if you if you've already landed a
junior devrel so yeah thanks again my
name is Benjamin Spock if you'd like me
to review your resume review your
portfolio a link is in the description
to sign up the signup form will look
pretty much just like this and you put
in your email address your name social
media links what you're looking for what
industry you want to work in and the
more info you provide the more info I
can you know tailor this video to and
the more value I can try to provide you
alright guys well this video is running
long thank you for hanging in if you
watch to the end
thanks for checking out free code camp
and also check out my channel Benjamin
Spock on YouTube thanks guys have a good
one